pray for me and my family
it's been a great ride with you guys on
the bucket list Tick Tock star Harrison
gilks has died he was 18 years old
I'm making this video because Harrison
sadly passed away a few hours ago
Harrison's brother opening up about his
final moments he was not in pain when he
passed away and he was with his family
hey guys just thought I'd give you a
little update Harrison documented his
cancer Journey on the app I know I'm not
you know posting much but uh treatments
had me feeling pretty gross lost a
little bit
in the wake of his diagnosis he started
a bucket list video series and uh thanks
everyone I did get to meet Luke Combs
quickly going viral on social media
[Music]
his final video posted two weeks ago
Harrison shared the heartbreaking news
that his cancer had spread I love you
guys thank you for all the support
throughout everything him and his
friends got the opportunity to say
goodbye over the last few weeks and I
just wanted to come on here and say
thank you to everyone from around the
world for their support and their
encouragement it really did mean a lot
to him look at this fell asleep
foreign